i i think there's a krispy kreme by
every [ __ ]
i don't know i don't have one by my crew
yeah i get in hollywood
no no no there's no krispy kreme in
hollywood yeah there's i mean
no bro thank you i don't know
i don't think i've seen this bro that's
what i'm trying to tell you about look
at that [ __ ] up
hollywood krispy kreme yeah bro i live
off guarantee there is all right
chris speaker i don't think they're
underrated i just think
it's there's always a lot it's like in
and out
they're like yeah no i don't really [ __ ]
with in and out but people
love them like they're so popular i'm
not gonna wait for anything i'm not
gonna wait yeah
they don't have one in hollywood thank
you there's no christmas no bruh no
there's one
in k-town uh mid wilshire burbank
no i know that one on crenshaw that's
right about my appearance
chris shaw right there crenshawn um uh
martin luther king
but not necessarily hollywood they have
some in the surrounding areas
yeah kind of have to drive out mid
wilshire is pretty close to you dude
yeah that is pretty close to me
i don't know i've never i've never seen
it i never wanted to say a song
um west hollywood it says it's on
uh see that's that's the one west third
street that's about my uh what's this
oh wait no never mind that one is sk
donuts thank you sorry
yeah sk donuts is really really really
really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really really really really really good
k donuts is really i haven't
had sk donuts
hold on if you scroll over look at the
list what you see all the red dots oh
that counts as sk donuts yeah
it's just you're going to put donut
shops in there oh
you know your shirts yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah krispy kreme
though that christopher crane that one
and martin luther king about my parents
in the hood don't even go there the best
the best donuts voodoo
voodoo oh voodoo they have it out here i
live kind of close to
the the original one there's portland
right yeah that's when we played
portland yeah
we had it right they brought them to the
green room yeah they're wrong to the
green room
that [ __ ] me up bro i'm a glad yeah
just the chocolate
covered i was all cracked out on this
show that's the best and then side card
doing it
christopher king's probably third or
fourth because then there's also
there's also the donuts up the street
here yeah what's that that one's dk
dks yeah krispy kreme is like the in and
out yeah yeah yeah yeah they're like the
best like franchise i remember when
krispy kreme opened in colorado for the
first time
four hour line i mean it's insane oh
cause when they
i don't know if they did this with you
guys initially when they opened did they
were they giving out free donuts
no oh they didn't that'd be lit no oh so
they did that they did it but i remember
my boys we'd be like dying to see if the
light was on means they're fresh
yeah and you get that warm glaze that's
what i'm saying right
with some [ __ ] dark roast coffee
poppy get that [ __ ] [ __ ] out
yeah get that [ __ ] out of here
we cheated a little bit we do you know
what you want saturday so here's the
thing about miami
their spring break and the spring
breakers who are from florida yeah
came there and [ __ ] the entire
operation up because the city went on
lockdown i heard yeah so we couldn't
find food or anything like that
everything was shutting down like early
shut shut down so
so we weren't we couldn't find food like
i post mates it wouldn't come it's just
a nightmare
mine did because i went vegan he went
vegan which i'd rather just starve
so when did you move in i had seven
pringles for dinner in miami
yeah i said here's my [ __ ] dinner
thanks miami but it was a good time it
was the
i game he can suck this california dick
yeah he did so then
um at the restaurant my boy lex
was doing business uh no lex my manager
okay guys but he's really close to the
the manager of the hotel in an
intercontinental
uh veronica so they have a uh
one of the top steakhouses miami there
called toro toro
toro and they're chicken wings daddy oh
my god
i know right yeah god they were good but
so they would leave the kitchen open for
us
and after the show oh yeah so we had
great steak you ate there cat you and
stevie had it it was so good yeah yeah
how about that dessert is this chocolate
ball and they
drop it on the table and shatters
there's like ice cream and all this [ __ ]
yeah like
drop it on the ball he goes everybody
say bon bon three one two three
but he goes because the ball is made out
of chocolate sort of shattered
yeah it shatters the food was so good
there it was good
and dog miami everybody got an ass
everybody everybody got ass in miami
something miami is my probably one of my
top favorite cities you weren't ready
for it i was not ready
i've been there before everywhere you go
there's a [ __ ]
dime piece with a blowout ass everywhere
everywhere i i i i was stressed for the
girls with flat asses
like were they gonna do yeah what are
they gonna do and they weren't really
there
you couldn't really find them there so
you could tell the out-of-towners with
the
[Applause]
everywhere we went i told you about yo
dude we go to the mall we get coffee
we go to walgreens we went to cvs ass
ass
ass ass but there's also do you consider
that everyone's on spring break or just
no
no i think cause we weren't on south
beach
we visited it and i'm not a fan of south
beach that's like coming to l.a yeah
he's not a fan that's like going to the
walk of fame or that's like going to new
york going to times square
yeah then jay's tourist ass
oh let's go to versace's [ __ ] hotel i
don't know he's
it was kind of it was the most tourist
picture i think we've ever done jay
sanchez let me tell you why it was it
was jay idea because he's smiling and
y'all just looking we're all
yeah i was like he's all yeah look
at jay smiley
stuff i hate her [ __ ] i can tell you i
went to coffee and jay was like nah
let's go
oh yeah first of all we walked to here's
the thing you could tell we're from l.a
obviously haven't laid hat on yeah just
me and chappelle scream la we're the
only people on south beach in pants
and pants yeah everybody like we looked
so out of sweats
i'm in sweats and then i had to hide my
raging boner because there was smoke
shows everywhere we were at
everywhere i took that thing now man
also i saw y'all on jet skis as well man
the jet skis for the squad
i will help you real slow why are you
fighting again
i was [ __ ] terrified i was like just
go dude
dj just took
the guy just pulled up because where our
hotel was right on the on the water
yeah so the guy they just pull up in
three jet skis and we get off and he's
like teach us how to do anything else
can you swim out you're like a fish dog
he was cool i can't yeah you know so if
your friends get in trouble you're gonna
have to help them that's what you do
yeah i can't he bro he gave me very
little instructions he said
that's the gas ghost that's the break
that's pretty good it's pretty easy
going out there
it was fun but i was terrified because i
thought them [ __ ] were going to tip
oh you didn't know no so i was just like
they were like [ __ ] full throttle
and dj went racing one of the funniest
moments i just see jay filming
and brendan doing [ __ ]
i went to little havana by myself to the
marlin stadium got this dope ass marlins
jersey
they decided to go out on their own yeah
so we got on these scooters
because we he jay was like we got to go
to this art district yeah
i think it's called wynwood when would
you when would our district or something
like that
yeah the night before james was like
let's go to the art district i'm like
what are your instagram thoughts we're
just writing everything down
ricky and louise said yo that used to be
the hood like that
you know it's probably the art gallery
yeah so i guess they
gentrified that area but it's still
really [ __ ] good and so me and jay we
caught the scooters early in the morning
riding over there
the scooters stopped when we got in the
hood oh they already knew
bro it beeps and then it just shuts down
so like we're sitting here in the middle
of the hood and we're like not just
gentrify the scooters yeah first of all
first of all i'm like jay let's just
leave the scooters
he was like what he goes what why i was
like i was like if we just leave the
scooter it's only a hundred dollar fine
[ __ ] it and he was like no bro jay jay's
cheating we had
he's a penny bro we had to go a mile and
a half back
just to be in the area where we're going
to leave the dragon
no we had to like push oh dude and it's
and it's heavy
manual yeah they're heaviest yes and jay
was like he goes i'm not gonna pay a
hundred dollar fine i was like jay a
hundred dollars
i was like i was like i'll pay your
hundred dollar fine
yeah yeah like [ __ ] with ease but
yeah because we were
so close like we were just right in the
hood yeah and then the art gallery was
just right there
even though he's just gonna sit there
and be like no let's let's let's take it
it's just a waste of time
but even with the ufc like i want to
watch ufc in the back and we have to
sign into our instagram plus
jake was like yeah i want to pay for
this thing man i was like you better pay
for this [ __ ] thing
he's like i'll just find a stream like
[ __ ] you better pay for it
rita's like i pay for the jet skis
what you bully does look at these big
guys man and then
jay tried to scare me say they were
[ __ ]
he's like there's tiger shark chappelle
he's dead stairs he goes chappelle
there's tiger sharks everywhere
so don't fall off i went what's wrong
with you no i said i already paid for
this you're going to scare him out of
[ __ ] going
here's why i wanted it i wasn't [ __ ]
be like no no
but then i jumped in the water oh yeah
you jumped i lost my sunglasses those
ray bans which i love
i lost it because you jumped in i forgot
i had them on and jumped in the water to
swim around
and i could just hear jay going you know
there's tiger sharks in the water so i
got the [ __ ] out
but it was like yeah after a while i
started hitting the full throttle
okay okay yeah i see with your arm up
and everything yeah i was feeling myself
after a minute because
uh yeah i just thought those things
tipped easy why does brenda's look
bigger than yours
i had the big boy yeah the big yeah he
had the big boy okay what you asked me
and jay had the same one
like a car seat i guess so [ __ ] it was
comfortable for me bro
and then there was dudes with their
baddies on the back just ass
ass is out i guess yeah
there was just instagram thoughts on
yachts all around around
waving at us and [ __ ] felt like you're
going
it was so funny watching jay just film
it was like the most big brother moment
ever he's just
kill me yeah i just kept doing it
but did you ride jet skis before yeah
that was my first time
well we could tell oh you went slow hell
yeah yeah
damn but i love miami dude bruh i got it
that's my [ __ ] city
i missed you shout out to miami we
didn't try cuban food though
because [ __ ] everything was like
closing i know did you go to like
by the clevelander area yeah we walked
by there okay we went to open locker
did y'all go every it was so funny
because every fan
came up to me that came with me after
the show they're like don't go to
opelock
listen they're like i love malik and
they all said don't stay in opel
man i got family out there shout out to
opa locker what is this opelock of the
hood or something yeah it's kind of like
that but it's newest gentrified
you know oh i'll tell you what i'll tell
you who we didn't see besides stephen
kat
you stevie and kat you know miami's open
year round
you guys don't need to go when we go
again justin you know miami's open year
round like i don't
you know you can go whenever the [ __ ]
you want they was like nah we're gonna
enjoy this vacation yeah justin is doing
the goddamn thing yeah he was
yeah you didn't see it you didn't see
him not at all no not at all barely
you show up like late show everybody and
then while we're outside waiting for
uber
he drives up y'all all right and then we
were like oh we could really use a ride
he's like
you're in your mom's car with his mom's
car and i kind of like dirty yeah
he's like ah i would help we're
literally standing there waiting for
this uber human as [ __ ] outside
is gonna say y'all good y'all all right
and just take off all right man
we didn't see him huh no we didn't
really see him at all but those shows
were lit man
you walk outside every night literally
walk out the crowd every night
and they're just like [ __ ] lit and
also the most beautiful people
i think i've ever seen you know how
usually my crowd is like all [ __ ]
[ __ ]
dude it was just filled with diamies
mm-hmm
at all weekends i know
i was standing by the merch table with
jay yeah and so many girls were asking
for like
a big girl and he was like we normally
don't bring it because
it's always at the shows but like
there were so many uh women which i'm
like damn this never happened no it's
not like i've been touring with this guy
since june it's all good it's
always it's my dad did y'all see salt
bae
who's that oh he owns the restaurant out
there and he's shut down
who sat down i think dude and why i mean
shut down like thursday night we're like
that's not a big deal we'll go back over
there
but the bars were closed at like
midnight like shut down because
listen i think all the spring breakers
yeah the curfew they came from atlanta
tore atlanta up then they went to miami
yeah because they're not from like
florida people when i mentioned it on
the show they'd boo the [ __ ] at them
because they're oh that's
everyone's like they're not from here
man those are out of towners [ __ ] up
the city
damn oh this this this guy yeah yeah oh
he has heels they call him salt bae yeah
i know that's what they what's his real
name cause i feel cool he got real
famous
doing that [ __ ] i remember that one he
feeds that one dude
he's a girl in the dudes what the [ __ ]
she's like deep throating that [ __ ]
fillet what i should really say she's
like what in the [ __ ]
any uh uh salt bae try to deep throat uh
pulse uh the guy amore cooper for dallas
and he was like man i'm not with all
that yeah
i mean oh so that's oh yeah yeah he's
famous for doing that
but he's probably a really good cook
though i'm sure yeah probably
yeah world-renowned chef
yeah he's yeah he's putting salt on
there he's making millions
of that knife like that and he's out of
miami yeah he's in miami yeah
i think i literally can't get over miami
it's probably literally you still like
so mentally
yeah you three three hours behind yeah
no punk though
he probably do something different to it
though
damn was he was he famous before the
whole
the way he did the song that's why it
made him huge
but he's obviously a [ __ ] world
record chef yeah
man cook for the best man i thought
y'all was gonna go out there man
we probably would have if everything
wasn't so locked down like you didn't
want to try doing that
i was the only one and then we had the
the contact at toro toro so we just kept
going yeah it was
it was just cool and it was great food
but then last night saturday we
ate fat we ate because we got diet we
ate fat we got done late and they were
like hey we just left food in your room
so we thought all the boys would go back
and eat so it was just food
yeah the burgers burgers the [ __ ] uh
this uh the sausage that you know that
sausage that we had
then i could have sausage
for a tour of miami all right yeah that
place was dope yeah we we got it yeah we
got to hit miami again
right okay it was just i will never go
back during spring break though
oh that's literally like the worst worst
time to go okay because
yeah well i think it'd be better next
year everybody just wanted to escape
you're showing together in spring break
no that's not yet yeah
that's not true i don't know when they
have their chill moments of miami but
yeah i don't know the spring breakers
yeah did make it we were the ugliest
people on south beach we were the
ugliest people there it was like zoo
cultural
yeah yeah yeah we can't escape okay you
can't escape y'all gotta constantly get
reminded it's just like oh i gotta
accept this [ __ ] and then you go to the
zoo culture on monday where the ugliest
in the yeah
yeah everybody got beautiful accents and
[ __ ] man i'm like
miami even the dude yeah but even the
dudes are like
[ __ ] jack chisel uh had the most
clean
lineups oh and how about the versace
outfit
outfits
[Laughter]
correct like i i wore like jean jackets
you can't even wear jeans like you i
didn't pack enough underwear
i'd go through three underwear a day
because you're so humid you're just so
glad
you just want to shower all day you just
want a shower okay we did walk around
with our shirts off
uh oh after the after the jet skis
though he was walking around well yeah
y'all didn't care we let him hang out
yeah yeah you had girls on yachts you
had dudes
yeah i mean we were the worst looking
people but like yeah we look like [ __ ]
bro i haven't walked around like in
public without a shirt on
you know how was it was the first time
coming out yeah first time coming out i
was like
yeah those short shorts on yeah i did
had these short shorts on i was feeling
myself leaving it living his best life
yeah new sunglasses new sunnies
new sunglasses wait what
jazz look dope and i know jay has a
million sunglasses i'm like [ __ ]
gifts
because he was like i'll send you the
site i'm like dude
sunglasses they said i would see you
today
i'll send you the site no it's right
there you're i think chappelle posted on
his instagram
what did you say your new sonny's
no you didn't send me that picture
really no you didn't post any picture of
it
no you didn't send it to me damn why you
so stiff in that picture which picture
that one
because he said pose and i said all
right oh word
i'm almost at that hundred thou oh are
you up there
i think i'm almost there yeah yeah i
remember doing a giveaway once you get a
hundo yeah once i get to a hundo
almost there almost there bro you was up
in phoenix bro a while and now
you went to phoenix yeah but you see him
hit a baseball huh oh i'm killing him
screaming oh man hit him hey what did i
tell you hoes because we had to watch
before
before the ufc they had on uh women's
softball college softball
and jay was like man can you imagine
like if your daughter played softball
going to the games i'm like [ __ ] i
would be in face paint with a photo oh
yeah i'd be traveling
a gator's tattoo on my neck if my
daughter played it i wouldn't
it is insanely boring to watch and jay's
like they throw [ __ ] fast on like no
they don't
he's like yeah they don't like no they
don't he's like dude they're throwing
like 60 i'm like not
a [ __ ] chance okay are they throwing
underhand at 60.
so chappelle looked it up 25 miles an
hour
i will [ __ ] barry bonds those hoes
25 miles an hour underhand
now i was with a lot of uh dodgers
and uh padres oh working out at the
working shout out to kevin bay
i got kevin and a guy through he was
like throw a light fastball
35 miles an hour that's 35 i think come
fast
now think about a hundred things oh no
he threw a honey i was like stopping
oh did you show it you can't even i mean
don't play with me like that a hundred
hundred's avid get that [ __ ] yeah all
right wait oh is that a machine
no go back go back ten one time go back
you did not
just show us a video you hitting a
t-ball bro
that's a t-ball that's not a t-ball it
is right oh you
[ __ ] you had me confused [ __ ] yo you
see malik and
a table what are you nine where's the
where's the where's the the mlb pictures
on the heat
i was so excited i was wondering why you
didn't bring it up yet i was sitting
here like
talking about the he hit the [ __ ]
ball come on man it was it was it was
here's the thing they they took away my
confidence because
when i saw a hundred miles will you see
a hundred miles
down there for me okay it's different
it's terrible it's scary
ain't touching it put like this pros go
if you go three for ten you're in the
hall of fame
bro imagine our dumb asses yes and it's
not the average speed
no no no hundreds heat 100 and they have
this what's the average pitch jen
i would say it's probably 80 something
eight and 90. probably 90.
they had they had this gun they had this
gun
and you got through it and i was like
ain't no way i didn't even see it
uh 93 93 record average of 93.
so average is 92 so if you're a pitcher
pro
pro in the game yeah you're throwing 90.
i didn't know it was so far back it's 60
feet it's so
far oh i didn't know it's so far bro i
didn't know so the guy he said like yo
have your elbow up and turn it like god
use this arm to guide it
you threw one i threw one but it was how
fast was it it was
28 but listen here's no but well it's
like those celebrities when they do the
first pitch
yeah they don't do it from the usually
it sometimes they do from the mound but
usually they scoot
like the girls you ever ever see
my first pitch like i threw it was like
50 cents you don't realize and it's a
mound it's
like you're like this like it's a
mountain oh so you're at an angle
yeah yeah that's just insane baseball's
insane
this amount of skill you got to [ __ ]
have bro a little bit
imagine you see 100 i didn't even see
the balls that broke no now imagine them
throwing like junk at you like
curveballs and screwballs and
knuckleballs and you have no idea where
it's going
and it's not in the strike zone oh yes i
mean not a lot again
you hit three out of ten you're bawling
three out of ten yeah
what was my boy mark mcguire doing uh
he's retired and he's on steroids
but uh oh yeah but 300 but
he was hitting more than three out of
ten no no [ __ ] no oh if you have a 300
on average i think the leader was like
my boy nick anderson for the
white sox last year his average was like
360.
so you're mid you know almost four out
of ten
also they go faster now though yeah yeah
yeah you know they were based they
pitched like this they wasn't even they
had a spring training game later on yeah
he was like y'all just warm up
and he threw it so fast and then he's
like i gotta leave nothing
where'd you go i was i'm done oh did you
go to uh jt's wings i didn't go to i get
it oh unreal no i don't know i'm sorry
that should be
as
i'd pay a thousand dollars to fly those
wings out here right now oh that'd be
great yeah it's so but you can't eat
that though y'all on the diet i would
eat that okay you gotta break it again
yeah
i mean i would my girl made her wings
last night she did
oh god they were nice air fryer yeah
they were great
healthy too healthy yeah bro i went to
the
i was telling chappelle it's in the car
bruh now correct me if i'm tripping
right so after the workout worked out
heavy with my boy kevin bay i was like i
need a massage he was like go to sunrise
massage park
that's what she already the name strange
okay i didn't know sunrise yeah so i get
there
i see a subway i see a 7-eleven
are we desean watson you're getting
jacked off dog
i thought i was but i didn't listen and
again i get there the guy is laying down
like this
and he's oh you ca you know it's during
the day he's oh all right he was laying
down waiting for customers
now like that asian guy right so he's a
gold backer
cool whatever he's like what are you
getting i was like a full body asked if
you've been here before
no you didn't okay okay so your red flag
but he probably he probably knew you
ain't never been in there before yeah
not a lot of black people now that
that's a code word though
oh it is you've been here before because
you know oh no oh
got you you know you play with that
booty hole
okay okay so he comes back he was like
yeah we got masseuse ready for you so
i'm getting a girl or something like
that
guy shows up ooh so i was like okay cool
again dishonesty that's
cool though no not cool i'm here you
know you can recommend a female i
i don't like i don't do male you don't
do milk no i can't relax
it's just too it's too erotic it's too
like
sensitive you rub it on me yeah you're
rubbing them yeah and i
you're really gonna get in that ass like
that they're getting their ass
that's cheeks i didn't ask for that i
totally stay away from the ass cheeks
yeah okay cool
so uh because again uh a small asian man
small obviously you might as well asian
girl
the same strength usually it was the
same history
when they're small asian men same
strands
i don't know i
because that that guy was massaging me
so god damn hard
really bro bro
i'm not lying to you like i was like you
got in there oh yeah the real deal holy
feel
listen this guy was how much was it it
was 58 god this has happy ending written
all over it
again do me a favor google that
do this go to rubmaps.com are you
waitmaps.com
and type in the name of this place okay
we'll find out if you went to happy
ending place
okay what is it what does it do is
suspend it oh how
dare they oh what is this dishon stuff
uh
there's also that shooting in atlanta oh
yeah okay rub maps
rub maps no yeah that's it
oh right now this is how you find out if
you're going to a happy ending type in
sunrise
uh massage uh at uh sunrise
sunrise and there's gonna be a million
sunrise but let's see what happens
in uh sunrise florida
let's see it's probably not a happy
ending place yeah it's probably i
guarantee it
they ain't gonna promote that european
sun sunshine
oh sunshine there this is something
chinese [ __ ] yeah
right there that's it oh no it is it is
dog there you go oh it's a rubbing tuck
yeah how do you know what did you say
because it's on his way masseuse
ethnicity
chinese there's two reviews scroll down
chrissy ask for chrissy ask for cucco
and if you want to see the premium
they'll tell you how you get it done
yep there you go okay solved
i could add chrissy i could have chrissy
and i got chip i'm sorry
yeah cuco or chrissy but you went with
greg
and he was digging like he was hurting
me and then i was like
i'm trying to take you know he's only in
there like if if he thinks he doesn't
trust you or whatever he's like [ __ ]
i guess i'll do this bro hold on i'm
glad it's more to the story
so he's massaging me i had to literally
stop him like hold on bro my ally
stop like stop hurting me yeah right as
i look up
you know you know it's curtains yep i
see so when they they said like yo
change your clothes
they get you give you these shorts wait
did you have a room to yourself no
you had a room yeah was there red lights
it was red lights what are we doing dude
why wouldn't you get jacked off this is
a signature
signature venue for happy ending
red lights no curtains
the [ __ ] dudes sleeping as you enter
the room
he's like oh [ __ ] you here for cuckoo
nah man i'm here for greg i'm here with
griffin
i just want
textbook
yo he said hey man you cool with 30.
i can't do the hour though an hour ain't
it i don't have an hour in me man
you're cool i haven't done this in a
while you cool with 30. are you cool
with
i've been here all day usually for this
that place is
signature happy ending i didn't know bro
they had the right
to a subway somebody you could have got
an innocent you could have got a six
inch this
this should have been your day okay this
story should go like this okay yeah man
i went to sunrise massage parlor got
jacked off by cuco
and then got a six inch [ __ ] meatball
sub what a day
what a nice day that wasn't me i like
that you went meatball yeah
that's awesome that's a good one okay we
don't [ __ ] with the tuna because you
know it's not real thank you yeah okay
if i do it also i'll do the six inch
i'll do the footlong oh with a full [ __ ]
well
yeah i cannot finish the food they put
that parmesan cheese on top and you we
know that's not real meat bro
yeah i don't know i don't know you know
what they do sometimes too throw no
pepperonis on there
[Applause]
what is this the greatest saturday of
all time how was the weather popping it
was great oh
dude and then you hit some fastballs
with these pro mlb players
what a great saturday afternoon but
instead
you had greg rub your heart i didn't
know and demon get a [ __ ] foot long
and then didn't they almost rob you oh
yeah that's what i'm saying so look dude
this place is so cliche happy ending bro
so when i'm face down
always you know so you know when you go
face down they have the hole in the face
yeah
yeah so you're like this and can barely
breathe yeah and then if it's a real
massage you're no search running yeah so
it's a happy ending you're just
you're rock hard with your boner so you
take your shoes and you put the money
in your shoes so you have eyes on the
shoes oh
i just what i don't know that's what
them i heard wait wait
i've never been there and a friend told
me about rub mats but i'm just saying
you could have had a different
experience are you serious yeah you
could have cucco or what the [ __ ] your
name that's who tried to rob me
so i look up she's hot no so she goes
nah she wasn't how cause she had the
mask on i can see too much
but again he's rubbing me i look up and
i have all my wallet my phone
everything in that bin because i have
different pair of shorts on and she's
going through it i'm like what you doing
and she was like no i'm moving the fan
i'm moving if they haven't been on the
whole time
and i was like hold on are you trying to
rob me and it was like
the guy's like not not not no she'd get
the fan i was all right
they're looking for that cash daddy
they're trying to get that mood
because they clearly they he's not here
for a dog did they have the sprayer with
the oil in it
yeah yep this is signature [ __ ] happy
ending
shout out to sunrise
you can add such a nice experience man
all right handy at the front
the bowl of candy yeah they always yeah
yeah this is great man every massage
fall i had
i cannot i could not get a [ __ ]
massage to save my life oh i love them
i love them too
[Laughter]
i don't know about sunrise massage like
an actual massage i [ __ ] with
you you never like so you never say get
a dude
never no i can't i can't relax with the
guy i know it's probably a better
massage because you know they're strong
but dude you get some of them those
little thai girls walking on your back
are they walking they walk oh yeah they
have bars in the [ __ ]
stomp on your back ah yeah you feel like
a hate stomp like [ __ ]
a haystack that's nice crack all those
the [ __ ]
did you get massages one one time i did
like
a couple weeks but i went to like a
little franchise one
you went to massage envy yeah
professional yeah
oh yeah i saw jimmy's yeah i want to go
to a real hashtag
wait when they tell you to change your
clothes you're not supposed to
so when they come back wait were you you
were naked that's what i think they were
trying to see if you're a cop or not
right so if you if i didn't change it
[Laughter]
you know you're fine
if you're looking for that type of
action you should be butt naked face up
when they walk in the room that's what
they say because cops aren't going to do
that
and then they always ask have you been
here before and it's always cash
cash right yeah yeah yes i mean i mean
the they have
reviews on rub matt not from greg it was
just it was just not from yeah name's
not
greg not on there ryan's not on
hey i didn't know bro i really wanted a
massage and you know was it kind of
outside things
like was it like it wasn't like next to
like the shopping center like the mall
yeah what was it next i told you a
subway a 7-eleven yeah yeah
across the street was a gas station yeah
yeah so that was all signs that that's
all
okay rub and tuck i didn't know look at
chin searches cat you get massages
no i don't you don't like it either um i
just never really went out of my way for
one
i feel like i need it though would you
do you do it yeah
if it's a real massage well people don't
like it
if it's a real massage i can get my
wrist my feet yeah
my glutes some people hate massages like
jay doesn't like to be touched
yeah neither do i don't like yeah he's
on camera when people come up and like
touch my shoulders and [ __ ] i'm like
yeah jay also hates that yeah i don't
like it he would never do a massage i
love massage me too
if they're good there's nothing better
yeah bro it's the best thing at all but
again i would never do it with a guy i
felt uncomfortable i didn't know you can
ask for a woman
you know i just thought they assigned
you a masseuse yeah
no they knew you weren't there for the
yeah i told them i told them i was like
there was an app i used where they come
to the house
i forget what they're doing oh they come
to the house yeah it's like running or
something like that i had that on my
birthday it's great
and they bring all everything they bring
the kid together yeah they bring
everything they don't really do that
yeah does it does doesn't get a massage
like make you kind of like nauseous
uh it can make you sick because it
releases a bunch of toxins so if you're
like starting to get sick it'll
make you sicker oh really like your nose
are running [ __ ]
i'll tell you what i'm doing if i'm
running down i don't want to massage
because it makes me sicker if you if
you're what
if i'm like run down like i want to get
one now so you have to be like like
remember
lex set me up with massage miami but i
was like i'm good man because i could
tell i wasn't getting good sleep
yeah yeah yeah we didn't like we didn't
like the hotel we we
well we like the hotel we don't know
hotels you know i stay in a hotel airbnb
yeah that's because you don't really
[ __ ] like you don't hang there's no hank
yeah
i feel so distant from them right jay's
on the floor with those big sweets
yeah big ass sweets oh yeah two rooms
i had a button that would [ __ ] lift
up the blinds and [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
uh-huh
but i just don't like hotels wow you
guys couldn't find an airbnb
because of spring break yeah it was a
nightmare it was it was like
10 grand a night or they were just all
reserved
for spring break mm-hmm insane nuts damn
that was yeah
10 10 12 grand a night airbnbs damn hard
pass
hard pass even like yeah i stayed in the
hotel at the palomar downtown i could
just tell i was really that's why i used
to work i'm an alumni
there bro yeah i worry oh yeah they love
it oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
you worked hard yeah shout out to
somebody i tried across the street from
uh stand up
live right yeah i'm surprised you oh
duval was there yeah
and so jersey shout out to jersey she uh
is like yo
uh trying to give me a guest spot
because little duval can i say this
yeah okay look duval did like 25 minutes
as a headliner oh wow and out there that
makes these all out of material
no they was just rewriting he's working
on that whoa he also
a minute on his uh ig that his friend
who used to perform with
uh that he would tour with cool he died
that was the last time he touched the
stage in 2008 and
touched the stand up live stand up live
stage oh
so it's kind of like a sentimental thing
so he was like going through it he's
going through
five minutes like he told three stories
and left so basically yeah and he came
with two so she was basically saying
like yeah so maybe don't do that venue
or he's just this his way of like
getting over it trying to cope i guess
i'm sure he because you gotta fi yeah
that's contractually
like let's say friday night when i when
i'm real late if i was like hey i'm only
doing 20.
they're you're contractually you have to
a certain amount of time otherwise
because
the club if the club want to be
sticklers they could definitely not
paint
yeah yeah but the way some headliners do
it shitty headlines
duvall's a monster yeah he's a beast
he's so talented so this isn't a
defaulting
but there's some guys who go on the road
that only have like 20 minutes
so they'll have like their feature and
their opener do 45 minutes each and then
they just do 20. they didn't do that
they didn't oh really he just did short
shows yeah that's why she was calling
for a guest spot and he was like nah
he was real strict oh wow yeah i guess i
understand that the
duvall's level like you don't want to
just a curveball in there
but it was sold out every night oh so i
need a monster people
walk around people walk out like man i
was expecting more
he'd tell he told three stories and he
was alright good night
and i watched he shouldn't just be he
shouldn't tour there then if if that's
where you're at yeah but maybe he didn't
know to you on stage and just
it reminds me oh yeah probably yeah
probably try to do it in i mean a
reminder of everything
about love i was watching i mean dupont
is a beast he's so funny yeah he's so
funny i instagram stop
deleting his account yeah what is he
posting weird [ __ ] though no he don't
want anything crazy he's just funny yeah
and why then why did they
no they'll deactivate it sometimes like
affected the terms and agreements of
what you can and can't post they did
that to uh
what's he saying i love him
it might have been just like stuff that
no maybe
but like probably rubs the wrong way
they reported he gets taken down
basically saying like yo now he does
lobby for women he'll go like yo this
girl is 25
no kids and getting her dm's first oh
yeah oh he has a that's he has a thing
called auntie of the auntie of the week
yeah
exactly which is funny nothing wrong
it's it's [ __ ] it's just funny
way worse [ __ ] he's just got he's got
great energy i think
he's one of my favorite people to follow
on instagram he's always like
him and schultz are super close yeah
he's always pretty upbeat
like just happy dude i don't know
he does a lot of stuff like that and it
cracks me up dude how about how about
chet
hanks our boy white boy
let's take a little break from the
shenanigans with the boys because guess
what it's march madness
baby there's only one place to place
your bets we're talking about draftking
sportsbook
draftking sportsbook america's top rated
sportsbook app is putting new customers
in the center of the action bet one
dollar
on any tournament game and if your team
wins you win 100
it's that simple dog gonzaga is a beast
probably gonna win it all
bet one dollar on gonzaga win 100 that's
how
freaking easy it is says pick any
college basketball team
probably gonzaga kids pick any college
basketball team that's still in the hunt
for your shot
at winning 100 all it takes is one
dollar bet and the team winning their
next game
there's no better way to put your
college basketball knowledge to the test
than put your money where your mouth is
with draftking sportsbook
don't worry if you don't know college
basketball again
i'm giving you one here gonzaga is the
powerhouse there but if you don't want
to do that draftking sports
offers daily odds boosts on pro
basketball hockey
golf mma we got you covered and so much
more draftking's a safe secure and
reload
reliable so you can deposit and withdraw
your funds whenever you want
download the top rated draftkin
sportsbook app now use promo code
fighter
when you sign up to turn one dollar into
100 if the college basketball team of
your choosing pulls off the win
that's code fighter to turn one dollar
into 100
for limited time only only at draftkings
sportsbook
must be 21 and older new jersey indiana
or pennsylvania only new customers
restrictions apply
see draftkings.com sportsbook for
details gambling problem
call 100 gambler in or in indiana
109 with it that's draftking sportsbook
promo code fighter stuff like that and
it cracks me up
dude how about how about chet hanks our
boy white boy something
like boys
i love chat what about him declares
could be a white boy summer
he's like i'm not i love the video he
goes i'm not saying it's gonna be like a
trump white boy so i'm saying white boys
like me
john b john b
yeah i play this chip bro i love it i
gotta hear it why are you trying this
gum no hey guys
i love this i just wanted to tap in
really quick tap dab
tap tap happy um that this summer is
he's about to be a white voice
i co-signed this by the way about like
trump uh
you know nascar type white i'm talking
about you know
you know me john b
jack harlow
yeah i can't believe people are upset
about this oh people got mad about that
yeah why people are mad come on
he goes i'm not talking about trump
that's what he's saying no people get
upset
me john v check harlow how great is that
it's so funny just
funny it's funny man he's just being
funny
yeah it's so funny but i'm gonna
challenge chad it's gonna be a thick boy
summer
it's gonna be a big boy thick boys are
in no we're hey bro we're losing weight
we are and i love you for that we're
we're doing it together people say it
and i will go on this journey with you
but i'm here to i'm here to tell you no
matter how much weight we lose
we stay thick is in our [ __ ] dna
daddy bro i wish you could have seen
this no kendrick has loyalty in his dna
we have thickness in our dna
i will never be thin i've accepted that
okay and that's my brand okay my brand
that's my brows
i think it's thick in your arteries my
heart
i wouldn't even mind doing like a little
cardio this week
if we can do that you guys want to hit
the cal back to stairs
that's it no oh that's it yeah
oh that's not bad um wait how high
though how high
well go go to that one and go go the one
next it's been getting hot i ain't
trying to roll around
the one next to the picture is just on
we see the girl
all the way to the right all the way to
the right you go the one next to that
yeah
to the right of this doug see you so see
what you're on to the
the oh this one yeah that's there you go
that's it right that's what we're going
to do doug that's what we're going to do
is that where connie had his sunday
service no near there
oh okay well i hope we see a drink out
there yeah i've seen drake running these
that could be a stock market
bro we're going to take a picture like
that go up jim oh no i'm gonna tell you
looks like girls like that girl right
now i'm gonna tell you like a girl
not that guy yeah yeah yeah that's good
or we could do it like that batty
there's that kid
yeah i know oh yeah we're gonna do it
like that
let's do a picture we're doing i'm going
to take that example
how long is it oh like yo ass fresh off
of miami but
as long as you walk it or you know you
can run walk run walk like you can do
different phases oh you can yeah
cobras i heard the culver city ones are
creep
325 steps that's pretty long which one
is the 101 uh covers
i bet it's around the same what do you
think yeah nothing is
the the the the santa monica is steep
you think that's look at that brendan
that's the culver city yeah and it's
steep too you gotta like
look at that bro yeah and you gotta say
it's so steep you gotta take like
i think calabasas got some all right i
mean this [ __ ] looks like go to go to
that where that dude is
where right there uh-huh that goes deep
and you take it yeah that looks
like deep is fun you know it's not
regular stairs you gotta put some force
i don't want to pose like that guy
though bro it's like
i'm not feeling any of these poses yeah
well we got to be harder than that come
on my g
that's the same guy i think this is
longer okay yeah
it's just the shorts but i think sound
like it is right
but yeah the same guy
i think that's a blog yeah that's him
then
oh keep it up david david gave it up
he's probably
is he on a workout journal hey
let's go david let's go let's go
he was on he was on ellen running stairs
yeah for running the stairs wait
watch my other tv show i wish we had uh
who was that richard
richard simmons richard simmons i
haven't seen him since eddie murphy
another professor didn't think he hit on
you
he did first time i remember was an l.a
hit on me out of a land rover
what did you say i was eating at a corn
grill
in west hollywood and he pulled up and
was like hey do you know where
he's like dude and they asked me to go
with him
[Music]
eating a corn dog hold up i was like
what's up doug
what's up dog i should have went with
him just for the adventure yeah you
think ella will cover our weight loss
story
so hi guys we're back these two
[Applause]
[Applause]
that'd be so [ __ ] funny y'all just
come out
don't do the dance
so guys where did you know you was fat
well [ __ ] [ __ ]
so palace hit that pitcher hey what did
that guy do babe
bro you don't want to be choking you're
yelling that people keep yelling how
about one guy
yelled this is to me it was racist hey
it is right hey juan let's play is this
racist or not
they didn't hear it so let's let's play
if it is racist or not okay
some guy yells out do it back
do a backflip sharpie
what do you think sharpie shark that's
racist as [ __ ] that's right
yes that's why i went bro that's racist
right
and then you are no should he said it
now
but people did ask today hey we we
thought britto was gonna do the backflip
yeah [ __ ] please no
sharpie dude i would kick him out well i
mean
the the the security security ran up to
the dude okay good yes
personalized version of dance monkey
yeah exactly that's what it is exactly
that's exactly like what he was doing i
don't is it
do you find it right you call it sharpie
you can't because yeah sharpie yeah this
would be fair
i think i know i'm darker i'm gonna say
he is in a ballpark
yeah maybe but it's so funny because
yeah
i'm just saying like maybe just he was
so drunk he was like yeah
[ __ ] up sharpie and chappelle i think
we can only hope yeah
we're trying to yeah but i thought he
said chappelle because i heard you going
adam on stage oh my god hopefully i
guess shut the [ __ ] up which he did
after
he did shut the [ __ ] up after he came
back he goes do you know what he said i
was like
do a backflip chapel he was no do a
backflip sharpie i went
well that's racist though in the crowd
did they say oh oh
no no i don't know i can't remember
cause like that's when i get in like
that weird mode of like my anger
yeah where it's like but i don't want to
release my anger on stage so i have to
be like
i'll be kind of funny about it yeah
because whenever there's times where
i've like gotten angry on stage
and it's just audiences you're too big
to be just me i learned that the hard
way and when i let it out
the [ __ ] crowd just gets completely
like uncomfortable and it's hard to like
put them on their heels and they're like
oh my god and when you're a big guy he
can't get when i'm a big guy yeah being
a bigger dude
yeah and just like like yo what the [ __ ]
you just saying to me man call me a
sharpie
yeah what are you wearing any kind of
gray just integrated no using black
okay yeah yeah yeah i said it out loud a
few times do a backflip
sharpie definitely racist definitely
yeah for sure one thousand percent i
agree i agree a hundred percent
yeah damn but i know that bro
like i heard it even even a fan like
well i wrote
something i roasted him when i went out
there because he loved that king the
sting shirt
yeah and that was a different guy no it
wasn't same guys
same guys it was a group of guys oh they
got kicked out they got kicked out yeah
because they they were talking
during my show and i started roasting
for their homemade crafts and art shirts
yeah yeah i said man sixth grade paid
off and started lighting them up and
then they kicked them out
yeah because they started talking yeah
yeah not really oh yeah
i didn't i just i didn't think they
should have been kicked out for that but
i think what happens is people just get
like it sound lit
they watch audio these shows sound lit
they watch us they watch us [ __ ]
every week so they just get so excited
yeah when they see us
you know like i mean and they just want
to like
say here is talk to yell out do a
backflip even if you didn't say sharpie
but do a backflip like halfway through
like yeah like what the [ __ ] yeah
you have to wrap yeah
yeah let me just put the microphone up
and [ __ ] do this for you hey bruh
this i knew these fans were real cause i
didn't even promote
my shows in uh arizona they just heard
it in conversation when we had david so
on and then people was like rolly boy
they showed up i was like they showed up
yeah yeah it was only six months i
appreciate it speaking of rolly boy
yeah there's seven people that's cool
appreciate it
i didn't promote it but it was a strong
man
how about little brows hit the [ __ ]
mainstream la radio yeah
he's on the radio yeah i'm so happy he's
been going home it's on my instagram
i know but instagram's kind of acting up
right now it is yeah it's down what they
saying
it was down earlier but let's see
running up running it up
i got the top comment yeah as long as i
got my friends
what was that thing they're playing out
it looks stoked
[Music]
he got some heat for y'all man yeah yeah
he got some heat
man what's so dope about that dude
what's cny
chris kiss fm new york yeah yeah what
channel is that i think that's new york
97.3 um
la or new york new york central new york
oh number one music station
wow good for him yeah yeah uh
man that that guy's got like such a
solid [ __ ] uh
background story yeah i had i had him on
my podcast and we were just chopping
because
we've always [ __ ] with each other yeah
you know but i was like man there's so
i don't know why i [ __ ] with this dude
so much and it was the same like vice
versa and then
you get to know his like story story and
you're like damn
like keep [ __ ] going yeah bro keep
[ __ ] going i love little brothers
he had me come speak at his uh he works
at a
oh in burbank um it's not in burbank
it's it's actually
dr farmer units in woodland hills he
works at a
recovery center and he had me come speak
and it's like
i don't know he like watching him in
that zone
and doing what he does like helping
those you know helping other people out
in the recovery world it's just dope
and then dude then he [ __ ] has this
amazing talent
yeah to be able to [ __ ] you know and
he's hardworking like
to work yeah he's a great dad too
just the best dude you know i love
asking what drugs used to do
i know right yeah i remember you're done
crystal meth like once or twice bro we
were all about you're [ __ ] with that
heroin dog
shirts off oh you never [ __ ] with heroin
[ __ ] sam
i don't know he was touching this [ __ ]
yeah my feet were all up on you guys
my titties were in the water i wish we
had a
right now he rock hard yeah he he said
uh
he started with uh painkillers yeah
that's why i [ __ ] him up
oh that'll do it also hit some of those
he comes from like a small town
look there we are right there oh look at
him look at your face
look at my what look at your face dawg
he's just a positive dude if you're just
putting out the positive energy staying
out of your way
yeah like that's what's been the biggest
key for me to stay out of my way stay
out of my ego
yeah and just go and like try to be of
service basically
not even like doesn't have to mean your
love service every day what studio is
that chappelle
that's uh there will be and uh sorry
about my house give that out
yeah it's almost selfish like not to
that's what someone told me once when
they're when i was talking about music
they're like dude
if you make a song like someone else
could hear that and it could change
their day
like if you're able to do that it'd be
selfish for you to be like nah but they
don't want to hear it
be selfish and give it away that just
[ __ ] me up yeah that was crazy
crazy he's a great guy he's
he speaks so well he's worked his ass
off to
[ __ ] oh that's definitely we gotta
know right fireboy yeah
listen to the six you want to see rolly
boy on that you'll see on the ep
but uh we got some new music coming out
he's
yeah like i mean yeah i know it was like
it was good wood yeah
yeah what did you say pawn yeah that's
that's hard as [ __ ] yeah eddie is a
beast man now i want to make a
skateboard
you do nah hit up eddie eddie's eddie's
dope but
that's fire yo uh i wouldn't change the
topic but i saw the fight this weekend
and uh where'd you watch man i watched
it that uh so i was doing house of
comedy with adam hunter
and he had like oh do you know michael
johnson you know michael johnson
the fighter yeah yeah i know adam too
yeah you know adam as well it was
both there was like shout out to
brittany i said what's up um we was
watching the fights
they were in the audience and we were on
stage and i was like man i'm about to
watch francis
i was like man it's probably gonna last
like what or the whole fight or a couple
of rounds
he knocked him out in the second round
right and this is stipe you heavy on
steep
um i had francis winning yeah francis
winning i like stephen you like sleeping
you say he's
he's durable but the fact that he just
went through
crazy paid that easy john jules sure you
want that heat because listen let me
tell you something he can back out but
if you know he doesn't need to back out
they just need to pay him how much you
talking about man millions
it's jon jones that was a nasty knockout
his leg you know what's crazy when guys
legs go like that like when i knocked
out murko
his like ankle and knee like yeah that's
all weird
but because your body's like not tense
you know how when people are drunk
driving and like the sober one will die
because they tense up the guy who's
drunk usually doesn't die
because he's relaxed yeah i mean
sometimes everybody dies but some like
when i knocked out crocodile his knee
gets all [ __ ] up
and you always get worried about their
knees but in their legs
but the body's so relaxed it's shut off
that it doesn't they they don't tear
stuff in
if they were tense it'd be like like if
like if uh steep egg
did that in regular time you'd blown out
every [ __ ] ligament in the world
yeah isn't it weird that's so weird
about the body that makes sense
because you because he fell on it he
fell on it it's like
that voguing [ __ ] oh yeah the death drop
yeah
the wait what's the difference are they
yeah they're bogus [ __ ]
you got a rave they fall back and do
that i love that you know this
yeah cheerleading i mean the death drop
dancing
yeah look at this yeah they [ __ ]
watch you is that your best is that your
bell phone
[Music]
[Applause]
that's hard she's in height oh chilling
yep he has a goatee hey chin we're
wearing that nah i saw
all hair now you don't you don't have
the best eye for this
that's a guy right there 100 yeah that's
the guy which are you talking about
no we was talking about i saw a girl
with that next one hello
we know that's
[Laughter]
yeah i like how you do exactly what i
was talking about i knew exactly what
you were talking about
yeah right all right this is the
beginning hey he killed it
she killed him when he hired uh that's i
think they're all men
they're all men no
i'm not saying girls don't do these
competitions girls in this particular
video these are all men yeah
biological men okay what this one yeah
like right that's a dude that's the one
yeah i think that's a guy it looks like
cat williams does
that is 100 percent a man
and i'm fine with it oh gosh but back to
stuttgart yeah
steve didn't tear anything he's good
okay but yeah if anyone can figure out
uh francis john jones his iqs much
higher
fight iq but he's moving up in weight
though uh-huh he's like 240 what 240
listen if he fights like he fought his
last three fights again in light
heavyweight he'll get knocked out but i
don't think he will
oh i mean he was just bored yeah oh damn
this is a test form
francis listen i i got i'm touring
between the two because you tell i got
jon jones legs
and i also got francis back so i don't
know which one
carry on though so you think francis
beats him yeah i think francis
he's the favorite vegas things he's
going to beat him too i think so as well
and i love john but it was it was pretty
cool because i i've watched that first
fight uh
uh stipe and ganu before yeah and to
watch that segment it was it was cool
watching them
much better friend scott yeah yeah and
he stopped that take down i'm like yeah
yeah
it was actually it's like kind of
inspiring he's just all around
i thought it was cool they called you
the great value of francis
who did that who's they who are these
mothers who called it the
you ain't name names say them names
man who said it i mean i don't read i
already got called sharpie [ __ ]
i'm ready so much
sharpie a member of skinheads against
racial prejudice sharpies australian
subculture
this is opposite what skinheads against
racial prejudice
oh that's i honestly think
he might have been drunk honestly yeah
it seems like a huge
drunk yeah and seriously chappelle hey
sure
something like that wait that's race
and i was like man that sounds really
racist no it was sharpie with the heart
are you cause when i came back in the
green room and told everybody
everybody was like ooh yeah everyone was
kind of like oh
really yeah yeah sharpie yeah i wish i
had a water bottle
yeah demanding in the middle yes abandon
it
it's like don't demand me to do anything
but there's sharpie in the urban
dictionary too
this is the urban dictionary right yeah
it says
oh it is racist oh
is it racist yeah yeah i mean that's
pretty easy to solve yeah hard arch
sharpie
[Laughter]
i didn't know you learned sh i didn't i
mean yeah
yeah i mean cuz i've been dark all my
life i think i've heard pretty much
[ __ ] everything have you heard that
one before
yeah i never heard that oh really never
heard sharpie yes no really
did you sky that in high school no they
just called me black as hell chappelle
oh i like it i like that that one kind
of goes hard yeah it goes back as hell
chappelle you don't know black as hell
shouldn't
yeah frank sounds white frank is not
white frank what's that frank is a dark
mexican
oh yeah yeah frankness sound black
what's named frank morelle morin marin
you ever heard that joke you so dark
that when god said let there be light he
pushed you out the way you ever got that
one
uh yeah that's easy there's a lot of
easy ones
like sharpie's a little creative
[ __ ] no not really because it's
yeah that's that's probably that's kind
of dope what other ones these call me
black attack
i like that one black attack white yeah
black
did i give it to you already oh no kevin
yeah um
black bones i like black bones ooh black
bones kind of
yeah like roy jones but black bones
black bones i like black bones okay
i like that that's like a chapel black
bones
current events all righty yep
oh you already did the chet hanks hilary
hilarious
okay it's a big boy summer dog speaking
of krispy kreme uh they're currently
under fire right now because they were
offering people a free donut every
single day if they showed their
vaccination card
is this a problem uh people didn't like
that krispy kreme a donut company
was offering free donuts to people with
something that
was associated with covid and obesity
and covid
is a bad mix you're just saying colbert
added into it
he's so annoying well he can't talk
about trump anymore so
his show has his right he's so soft he
is uh which is great news for him who
got the shot but still as a death wish
cause you get one donut here's the thing
i don't think if one donut puts you over
the hill of dying
what are we gonna do what are we gonna
do
what are you gonna do uh how we're upset
that christopher's giving out free but
also
to encourage people to get a vaccination
that's the world we live in
right it's kind of a weird thing i i
couldn't i don't know i just try to find
i'm i'm baffled how soft people are like
how soft society
is i think like they're giving you
they're trying to promote you to either
the vaccine you fat
[ __ ] it's also optional yeah it is
obvious yeah yeah
krispy kreme came out and we're like hey
we're a donut shop
so we offered you a free donut if you
wanted it
here's the thing if you're 400 pounds
you got more problems than krispy kreme
giving you free donuts bubba
also if you're 400 pounds don't go get
the doughnut
just get that vaccine it is it is weird
because i always try to whenever like
these things type of things pop up where
you try to play don't
advocate yeah i always go okay why
where's where's the [ __ ]
you know let me find it i think it's
it's so hard for me
to find it with certain things i go i
don't i just don't get like
why why the [ __ ] would i be mad mad
about it yeah
i think they just have nothing going on
with your life so it's like oh krispy
kreme let's attack them
yeah it's a weird thing to attack sam
actually posted something that was
pretty funny yeah he said cause you know
he's he's so hardcore conspiracy
did they is that him now
no do you think he got knocked or
something
you put his face unless he's like shadow
shadow man that's what i'm thinking
right now
you could probably just go through so go
to like
i follow him yeah follow him as well so
do i he's still up
go to work at you can probably look
through like go through your friends
your friends
yeah or like who you're following yeah
follow him
he only has 12 posts no that's not his
name
following there you go saying
i can't type it in though oh unless you
type it in no
oh man damn really oh there you go
right there it is yeah so here's shadow
banding right
he might be if it didn't come up in a
search i feel like you should what did
he say though
i gotta find it
you talking about donuts he was saying
like how the government wants you to get
shots first of all they want you to get
the shots and then they
reward you by giving you free donuts
yeah so diabetes yes something like that
yeah like you shouldn't trust again
diabetes just covered basically
oh here i think this is it is that it no
it's not
well that is so celebrity endorsement
for
the vaccine government backing laws
against those who speak out against it
are tech giants banning info about the
dangers of the vaccine
and he goes is the product you want to
avoid at all costs so not the donuts
i'll tell you something let me tell you
something uh krispy kreme whatever
nah that's not going to move the needle
on me getting a vaccination
i know now if chick-fil-a say they're
giving out free
you know
so what was sam's thing sorry oh it was
about something else but sort of
it's about the vaccine yeah it's not
that it was about it believes it all
any product that needs celebrity
endorsement then government backing
laws against those who speak out against
it tech giants banning information on
the dangers of it
and then he goes is a product you want
to avoid at all
yeah that's very strange right yeah yeah
they are pushing the narrative
uh about like yo vaccine get the
vaccination but also
do you think they go like yo try to
force traveling like yo you have to get
shots to travel overseas
well traveling is an option so you could
still say no but you just wouldn't be
able to
travel overseas some people don't
[ __ ] travel at all they're not gonna
do it
probably not in the united states but if
you're trying to get it back into the
states like i was reading a story this
morning someone went to mexico
and then the dude tested positive for
code so he stuck in mexico 14 days
before he could come back
so it ain't worth it to travel out hmm
[Music]
okay so i think we spoke about this
maybe a few months ago
j cole has been taking a break from
making music and everything and
um word is is that he wants to see if he
can make it
into an nba team yeah absolutely not
absolutely hey dude no he didn't no he
didn't
he never played an nba
yes he did he game in the game for
toronto raptors yeah go to that gym well
this masterpiece yeah that's what he did
so j cole was a walk-on
at um st john's with st john's badass
right they were good back in the day
look he played him he played right there
he got
in the game he played it in a pre-season
game
so he never played an official game but
he is pretty good he didn't
shoot up yeah and he had 11 points well
eight he had eight points
and he was on the squad let me ask you
this okay
let me ask you this do you think master
p would have got a shot on the toronto
raptors the view wasn't
master p no no yeah
no i mean no chance okay well yeah wait
dude you must be pretty [ __ ]
romeo uh play at uh usc yes yeah for one
year
oh really was he tight and then he
wouldn't that should be sons playing at
uh all black college now oh yeah yeah
he just committed uh hbc what's that
hbcu
[Music]
tennessee state yeah also um your man um
um the cornerback i can't think of his
name right now uh
uh primetime dion dion all his sons went
to uh
hbcus and he's coaching yeah so yeah
is that the new wave or is this trendy
there's little romeo that's a little
romeo so what j
cole is uh trying to get on the warriors
uh i don't know if he's trying to he's
just trying to get on
he's just he didn't miss any of his
three so they're saying he's really good
yeah he's like he's pretty good played
in college saint johnson pretty [ __ ]
good i don't know how he like matches up
against actual professional nba players
i'll take it from here
[Laughter]
draymond greens in his face you think
he's hitting shots like this true true
true
that is true like yeah start focusing on
stuff that he can [ __ ]
if that's what he likes to do cut the
hair your brother's favorite rapper
yeah that's right mm-hmm what else and
probably his favorite basketball player
now
nah i don't know okay so this skin like
a
two part this is a two-part uh story and
what i tell you
in in the green room jersey you see
little uh what's the little nozzle
i guarantee you those aren't real nikes
there's no way
nike's putting blood and shoes during
covet you know how big nike is do you
think they would
agree to do a collab with little nauseas
and put
[ __ ] blood in their shoes there's no
just
so many health issues wait there's okay
so first things first um
he released a music v video for his most
recent song
i've never seen him call me by your name
a reference to a movie
like modern day uh brokeback mountain
it's about two gay men oh my god uh and
then
in this music video he is giving satan a
lap dance
and people are losing their [ __ ] because
they're saying that he's pushing the
gay agenda that he's going to hell blah
blah blah
like oh people just very upset that he
makes music
that kids liked initially and they're
referring to old town road
and now he's making music where he is
giving satan a lap dance in a music
video
uh he then comes out and says that um
he doesn't make music for your kids it's
your job to parent your children not my
job to make music for them
he starts saying that you guys tell me
i'm going to go to hell and then get mad
the moment i do go to hell and give
satan a lap dance
and a few hours later or maybe a day
later he announces that he's gonna have
a shoe collab
and the shoe is a nike shoe that has 666
all over it's black and red and it's
supposed to have a drop of human blood
on it
nike came out and said that they have no
affiliation with this shoe deal and that
they are
buying these shoes individually and an
artist is making the design oh
he has no affiliation with it it's just
that they bought
a specific nike shoe for here's the
thing those shoes sold out in minutes
yeah they do they're a thousand i think
a thousand dollars thousand sixteen
dollars they sold out in minutes right
this made a collector's item thousand
and eighteen dollars
slow down minutes damn just doing it as
a promo for a song
oh got it i saw the cover i ain't need
to see the video i saw the cover one i
saw him tooting back
had his ass up and he had satan in that
chair so they said sacrifice just a cool
word it's just a
team that gave the blood oh one of ms
chf's founders daniel greenberg said in
an email and today as who collected the
blood mr green replied
uh yeah not a medical professional as we
did ourselves
no probably not even it's probably not
what what blood
type a i want to say oh
i don't know they did a jesus shoe
before this yeah i contained holy water
so this is their play on the satan shoe
did you see this oh
jesus yeah they're all terrible yeah oh
it's terrible because white with blue
i'm not into it who would wear a satan
shoe dude i'd wear a booty juice for you
though
yeah do like a thick boy themed one has
like
a peach emblem on it
[Laughter]
that sounds i mean it worked though it
sold out it's only 600 pair of shoes but
still
at a thousand dollars so you may you
would do a shoe collab though if you had
the opportunity big time
you did one with greats right everyone's
great yeah you did
great for dance that's the problem um
but they're a shoe based company based
on new york
they're dope they're dope yeah they're
great no problem
yeah we have them in here somewhere oh
foreign
the suede and black oh gotta find a kid
logo on them
they sold out in minutes too and we
didn't have blood in them
uh yeah there they are right there yeah
i seen those you had them uh
right there right there oh these ones
yeah they're an esquire magazine as top
10 coolest sneakers of the week
oh really shout out hell yeah put them
bad boy hey
see but i would like my own like
you wear these i used to all the time
yeah what size is this
that's a small one right is it small it
doesn't say the size on it
this is custom i don't think it's major
who might this might be i got big
those are collectors items no you don't
put these on but these are nice you can
tell they wore
yeah they're nice i like that handmade
italian
i like something like
whatever these are what are these these
are jordan shoes
those are fire jordan daddy's yeah we
got we yeah we gotta get you a collab
these are nine
size nine yeah so you're brian oh that's
brian's oh you're this is right here
let's go with
this one oh no let's not do this one god
damn it
yeah i picked the same ones as cat
hell yeah let me you guys playing this
before i was saying oh yeah
so louisiana uh mayor little buciana
he that him uh and that little the baby
your favorite rapper yup
shooting a music video in south carolina
now this this
video went viral talking about he
smacked the piss out of him
you paid the guy 500 500 but we didn't
know that but yeah he paid 500 no
now would y'all like let's say
times were bad right would you get
slapped in this and
it was a hardship i placed on 500 as
part of the music video like you like
let me see it
all right but i'm saying what would you
take a smack to the face
i need to tell you a dolphin anyway yeah
he's you know he's not all there
let me say that one more time go ahead
go ahead he smacked but that was for
that was this is
yeah that's part of the thing oh got it
smaller
is uh the baby the baby and a little
booster labour
but they didn't know he was gonna smack
him that hard was the guy like hey man i
need more than 500 for that
right you're gonna have to pay me more
than 500 look at the difference
so he gave him a thousand though right
because he got 500 from
uh busy and baby
you can't get tickets yeah yeah yeah get
a minute
they gave him a thousand yeah but the 50
it was fifty four dollars tip
oh so you got 550 yeah man
the [ __ ] out of them damn yeah
smack the piss out of him i didn't know
it was gonna be that bad god damn
yeah and you could just tell your dopey
probably hang out that uh
that corner store a lot yeah they kind
of take advantage of them right yeah
that's why i feel bad for you one of the
homies
yeah i kind of feel bad yeah do a homie
you wouldn't smell you got a guy
strung out on [ __ ] my head
[Laughter]
but i gotta slap the dog [ __ ] out creed
three you would
how much you paid no i wouldn't i
haven't i wonder how they're gonna play
that into the music video yeah
what what he smacked the [ __ ] [ __ ] got
him no oh no
that hurt the guy
yeah that is aggressive so there was a
wedding at mar-a-lago
and donald trump basically you know
usually you say something about the
couple
but he kind of just talked about himself
the whole time he's such a oh
that's so funny you know i just got i
turned off the news i get all these
flash reports and they're telling me
about the border
oh this is someone's wedding yeah
they're all
so press croppers
at the same time if you invite donald
trump to your wedding you probably love
this
[Music]
[Laughter]
how long did he go for she left this one
says
but that's all that they captured he
probably won 2024
hey man you just got married yeah that's
[ __ ] hilarious
the broom probably got like
this is uh i think a week or so old but
so this io
io wrestler spencer lee yeah we i
thought we covered this did we
i'm not sure if we did i remember this
okay well if we did it already i'm not
sure
yeah but apparently he won on two bro
two uh messed up a sales
dad what a beast third ncaa wrestling
championship
with no acls that's nuts is he like the
floyd mayweather wrestling
no no uh yeah stud though
okay and this is chris brown's leg
tattoos
yeah this is dope his kids names
oh that's stoked oh he got go goku small
goku on his leg
he loves that what's his kids he's one
of those guys yeah i love anime as well
nate nico or
nevo and royalty oh royalties he's his
daughter
oh he has uh he has on the supreme uh
ducks where let me see
oh [ __ ] he's spring sam daddy's getting
those
you getting those mm-hmm the tattoos
right not the no the shoes oh the shoes
well anytime
i'm getting tattoos on my leg not that
though that's a grass
that looks like that [ __ ] hurt oh my
god he got an eye on his kneecap
yeah sheesh that's pretty dope work
though
yeah damn that's well you sitting there
after a while you're kind of just like
all right
i knew through it he got a whole tattoo
of an angel on the back of his skull
who did uh chris brown like did he
really he has a whole
angel tattoo so have his skull is tatted
up
is that his tattoo artist yeah
now if you get a tattoo oh look at
that's his youngest one right jesus
christ
he's only got two kids right yeah yeah a
daughter and then yeah
yeah that's are you about to look at
that skull tattoo
yeah yeah look how big why are you
thinking about doing that chin
if i go crazy i'll go crazy i do love
school tattoos
and then once you grow out your hair you
can't see it just hurt
oh go uh just type in let's see what i
don't know i'm just typing head tattoos
this brown head tattoo i won't be
specific with it
oh [ __ ] oh that's really intense and
look at the other side go to the
yeah it's a bowl it's a bowl
and a woman huh do you grow hair back
there
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay oh and it's a
mortal kombat tat that's sick
yeah i got some head tattoos man oh on
the side of his head he has a mortal
kombat here oh that's
hard travis barker got some head tattoos
i love head and neck tattoos you just
got to be like
give it a certain level to do it yeah do
you do you of course you're going to be
like sedated
but how long do you think uh those
tattoos like go for on your skull
i don't know i think it probably depends
on how much pain you can take too if you
have to take a lot of breaks
that must be that what you're hitting
the the pressure point
is that now don't call me chris is that
can they
like develop ct as well no man no i
don't think so
okay because that is
gotta well this squad will be in naples
florida back to florida
bro we're on the road we're on the west
side this time though naples florida
april 15 to april 17th and then austin
texas tickets just went on sale april
22nd through the 24th
austin texas at the vulcan gas company
theater
austin texas gonna have some surprise
guests there's me a blast
austin texas naples you're on the clock
f-a-t-k-z
dot-com for tickets love you guys thanks
for listening we're out
we're watching bad teachers yeah that's
about cracking up
like it's so good i know that dry
humping scene cracks me
[Music]
university one
these my favorite shoes the off-white uh
oh no it's the easy ones he wears a lot
[Music]
for sending us to you know the care
package
flat feet hey you know flat food
are you a flapper are you flying with it
hell no no no you're not gonna arch
[Applause]
[Applause]
those are defender jordans two something
to do something a little
wait what what what what socks you got
on b oh
i was
austin april 22nd through the 24th see
you there
let's just smell something to do so god
damn